the taliban are stepping up their search
for people who worked for nato forces
the previous afghan government and
independent media militants searching
for a dw journalist killed a family
member
this even though the hardline islamist
group has tried to reassure afghans
since seizing power promising there
would be no revenge but many fear the
taliban have changed little since their
brutal rule in the 1990s and thousands
of people continue to crowd kabul
airport desperate to flee the country
an american soldier lifts a small baby
over the wall and into kabul airport
just one of many
but the striking images of children
being helped over the barrier to safety
are contrasted with others
of soldiers using tear gas to disperse
the overwhelming number of people trying
to get into the airport and on to one of
the flights that international forces
continue to operate out of the
afghanistan capital
american troops describe chaotic scenes
i don't think
people understand the chaos
that is raining right now
in the capital
the
brutality and the
efficient lethality the taliban you know
are using right now to
ensure
their rise to power
sourcing and verifying information in
afghanistan is becoming increasingly
tricky
some afghans and couples say the city is
calm
the situation is better now there's
peace here there's no firing no war
people are happy the reason being that
the islamic emirate of afghanistan has
come here and they've established peace
the taliban have promised that there
will be no revenge killings or violence
towards its opponents
but according to an intelligence report
provided to the united nations the
taliban have already begun going door to
door looking for opponents
united nations chief antonio guterres
says he's willing to talk to the taliban
but only when the time is right
i'm ready to speak myself
when it is clear with whom should i
speak for what purpose let's hope that
there will be a way for
an inclusive government in afghanistan
nato foreign ministers are also set to
discuss their future relations with the
taliban on friday
the issue at the top of the agenda will
likely be how they can calm the
situation outside the airport and get as
many people out of afghanistan
as quick as possible
let's cross straight over to kabul where
reporter franz marty is standing by for
us franz what's the situation for
afghans trying to leave the country
through kabul airport now
today sons in the airport told me that
the situation is similar to yesterday
meaning that it is still quite chaotic
nonetheless some people get in but a lot
also
remain stranded this has several reasons
as your report mentions there have been
reports that the taliban sometimes turn
people away meaning that people can't
even reach the gates to the airport
on the other hand there have also been
examples that people are told to come to
a certain gate to the airport show up
there and then there is no one to
process there um so they are not letting
in despite like doing everything
as they were told and another problem is
that like uh still some afghans stream
to the airport without being on lists or
having like the necessary paperwork uh
just in in the vain hope that they are
somehow getting a place on a plane and
they come there and uh yeah clock clock
the gates even more uh some people are
uh are getting in um but it is still
chaotic
we're getting reports friends of
taliban fighters going door to door
hunting down opponents and journalists a
family member of one of dw's own
journalists has been killed you of
course are a journalist what are you
hearing
it is difficult to verify there have
been such reports since days but if one
follows these up it's it's uh often um
it leads nowhere doesn't mean that it
doesn't happen that taliban went to some
houses and killed some people in fact
like for security forces this was like
well documented some weeks ago in spin
bulldog in the southern province of
kandahar however uh several of these
reports seem also to be based on like
questionable information
meaning that either it didn't happen at
all as reported or not on the scale that
it was reported again this does not mean
that it doesn't happen in certain cases
but so far um
i have no indication that this happens
like all over the place in a really
grand scale um that there are like moss
arrests or or mass executions
friends thank you so much once again
stay safe journalist franz marty there
in kabul
well many countries are preparing to
take in refugees from afghanistan india
is among them there's an afghan
community in new delhi made up of
refugees from an earlier generation who
fled the taliban the last time 20 years
ago
the indian government is currently
saying it welcomes refugees but critics
have questioned the selection criteria
the first step into a new life after a
difficult journey
they are the lucky ones who made it past
the taliban and arrived in delhi
people are very upset they're shocked
and they're scared yeah this morning
the banks ran out of money so
there was obviously a lot of planet i
can't believe the world abandoned
afghanistan
our friends are going to get killed
they're going to kill us
our women are not going to have any more
rights
that's all i can talk another day
many more afghans didn't make it
look it's an american plane
people even clung to the wings
and when the plane took off some of them
fell and died
now that the taliban have taken over the
country nobody wants to live there
anymore
26 year old jamshed could travel with
his son to delhi thanks to a medical
visa
but the fear still haunts him
and he's worried about his relatives
stuck in kabul
his situation is similar to a lot of
afghan refugees who have been in india
for a long time
this man hasn't heard from his wife ever
since the taliban took control
my problem is that my wife is stuck in
afghanistan over there and i'm unable to
do anything to get her out of there as
she does not have a passport i have not
been able to talk to her for the past
two days
afghan refugees are desperate to get
their loved ones to india
the country itself says it would
facilitate repatriation of those who
wish to leave afghanistan
at first the external minister tweeted
that hindus and sikhs would get priority
attention
a day later the ministry of home affairs
tweeted that it would introduce a new
category of electronic visa called
e-emergency x-miss visa to fast-track
applications for entry into india
irrespective of religion
but in recent weeks only a few refugees
have arrived from afghanistan
most of them were members of the
government or those having prior visas
as afghan refugees in india their future
is also uncertain
few receive citizenship
most just get visas that they have to
renew